hi my name is aveda from gate culture in
singapore how are you i'm will how are
you i'm good thanks for asking um that's
a new attempt to die is without a doubt
a very important film and a franchise
it's the 25th film and it also sees you
know daniel craig's last outing as the
iconic character what were some of your
key memories derek's in the film and
what was it like working with daniel
craig himself most of my memories were
just about racing against time
and thinking you know several weeks in
advance of
sets and locations we had to shoot in
and trying to keep all the units sort of
uh
moving in sync um but it was also pretty
exciting you know when when daniel came
to pinewood at first and you felt the
energy shift it's like bond had arrived
it's like elvis is in the building
and um
it was just a really real joy to to to
see all these amazing crafts people in
terms of the the department heads of the
film come together with their with the
cars and stunts and you know the these
beautiful sets and costumes and
these crazy devices that they would just
make in their little workshops is this
like santa's workshop was like you know
one building down so just the kind of
the the magnitude of the the production
you know was pretty exciting and amazing
most the time
and um you know when we got to fly to
these amazing places like whether it be
norway or jamaica or italy you know
scotland being up in the highlands was
just pretty amazing i'm glad you
actually brought up the locations though
because i feel like the franchise itself
is a very like
wealthy franchise like it's not just
filmed all over the world it also
kind of like defines spy movies that
carry
a good balance of like emotional
storytelling and action so
how do you think your past experiences
whether it's you know directing films
like the number like true detective and
being you know like a japanese american
director yourself has positively
influenced your making of no time to die
um i think a lot of times when you as an
american you can it can be very
isolating to say to to have a world
perspective and i think getting out in
the world and seeing things from outside
the the lens of just my own country has
been important in my formation of as a
creative
and a lot of my stories have aimed to to
show that you know despite being from
different nationalities or cultures or
religions uh many people around the
world essentially want the same things
out of life you know and the same
protections and and have the same heart
so you know i think you know as a as an
international man of mystery bond
obviously travels around the world uh
for the in the interest of queen and
country but i do think his his moral
compass goes beyond queen and country to
to you know humanity what's you know
especially those who are closest to him
lately you've been very vocal about what
no time today means for female actors
and extras of color moving forward
you've gotten the freedom to
re-interpret the james bond character
small to see today's audiences
um what are some things or changes that
fans can look forward to seeing i think
they can look forward to you know some
of the the women in in no time and i are
very interesting multi-faceted
characters i think leia seduce madeline
we get to see much more about her and
what makes her tick and see the kind of
agency involved in in their decision
making and and um
having a voice
um i also think it's interesting just to
purely on a time schedule to look at you
know if bond retired six years ago
what's changed in the world since he's
been gone you know if people are still
double o's like you know lashana lynch
playing a new double o uh what is it
that she can say about how the world has
shifted since he's left how do you think
these big changes you've implemented
will affect the franchise moving forward
i think i i don't necessarily think
they're very big changes i think they're
just what reflecting the times and i
think bond films have always in some way
reflected the times they're in you know
for better for worse and that this one
is i'm very proud i think of where we
got to with the character and especially
if you think of the the journey from
casino to here uh it feels like a
complete arc for that character
all right thank you so much this is all
the time i have i'm really excited to
watch the movie really soon well i hope
you like it